[Music]
joining me today is an activist and
author a snarky Twitterer Twitter Aurora
and co-host of the secular jihadist
podcast Yasmin Muhammad welcome to the
Reuben report thank you Dave thank you
so much for having me
yeah well I'm excited to talk to you I
feel the Twitter has wanted this to
happen so you have to sort of bend your
Twitter demand something right yeah okay
so for people who don't know you because
we got to know each other a little bit
in 140 characters over the last six
months or so who are you what are you
doing here so I am a ex Muslim author
and activist I very recently just wrote
a book memoir of my life called from
al-qaeda to atheism
and in it I described how I was born and
raised in Canada so you know a secular
free country but I had a very
conservative upbringing and when we say
conservative and we're talking about
Muslims it's it's incredibly
conservative so I so what does that
actually mean
so a job was put on me at the age of
nine I went to Islamic schools as
opposed to public schools as much as my
family could so like throughout
elementary school and then there was no
public school for her there was no
Islamic school for high school so I
ended up going to a public school and
then I went to also for one year and
then I made friends and I was becoming
to westernize so then my mom took me out
of school and just kept me home but then
that's against the law so then she had
to send me back again so it was you know
this constant struggle all the time in
my family with me just asking too many
questions and loving Canada too much and
my Canadian friends my non-muslim
friends and you know I was not the good
little concern
girl that I was supposed to be right so
yeah so after high school we went to
Egypt to just visit family and woke up
one morning and my family were gone my
mom had just left me there well and when
I spoke to her on the phone and what's
going on what hot like why did you leave
me here and she was saying well because
you're just too much
you're too much to handle here too much
trouble so I'll leave you there with
your aunt's and how much trouble can you
cause Anna again Islamic society right
those issues she felt like I was safer
there than how old are you at this time
I was 17 and this I mean Dave you have
it like I never did anything like I
never had a boyfriend I never drank I
never like I I compared to like regular
Canadian kids I never did a thing like I
was such a good girl right but I can't
even imagine what a regular Canadian kid
would you say would be so bad Canadians
are so polite yes in these days you know
yeah yeah but it just wasn't good enough
I also literally left you in Egypt it
was like you know what let Mubarak do it
yeah yeah pretty much
and what then what happened so I stayed
there for two years and she was trying
to get me to marry my cousin when I was
there and I was able to come home again
by telling her that I just wanted to
come visit Canada for one last time and
say goodbye you know so as far as she
knew everything was fine with the
marriage like you know I was going to
marry this guy and you know he's find an
apartment above law but once I got on
the plane I was like there's like unless
you're going to physically pick me up
and put me back on a plane to Egypt
there is no way that I'm ever coming
back to this country so I so I stayed
with her and I had nowhere else to go
these are the days before internet and
or Facebook and I couldn't contact
anyone high school friends I lost
contact with them for two years and so
it was it was a really bad time because
she just can't want me there
and I wouldn't leave who could she
wanted me to go back to Egypt and marry
this guy
so it was is more contentions
contentious than even all of those other
years growing up and so eventually she
pushed me into this marriage and I was
so tired of fighting at that point I was
like fine let's try it your way
let's see you know maybe maybe this will
work
maybe maybe you'll actually love me if I
listen to you like all I just I just I
decided to succumb yeah and I married
the guy that she forced me to marry what
do you say cousin is that well there
isn't because this isn't it guys yeah
the cousin is not ready oh now why she
came there yeah no no this is a new guy
in Canada now this is the al Qaeda guard
this is him yeah yeah yeah so I didn't
know who he was he was like cousin okay
okay thank you Becca I'm here yeah yeah
I didn't know he was al-qaeda I didn't
even know what al-qaeda was yeah but you
know it's positive for sex oh yeah okay
so you they find this other guy and
they're like all right we're gonna
arrange his marriage huh you basically
kind of throw your hands on the tail
I'll just try try your way but now we
have to clean this out kind of thing
yeah two for it yeah yeah so um I'm not
marrying living in Canada yeah well he
was he was in Canada for 9/11 so this is
this is prior to 9/11 so I didn't know
who was heaven in Latin was I didn't
know who al Qaeda were like so whatever
happening was my mom ended up having a
nosebleed but then also coughing up
blood simultaneously and so I called
9-1-1 and an ambulance came and picked
her up and I went with her to the
hospital and that was the very first
time in the entire marriage that I was
actually out of the house with nobody
around me like he wasn't with me my mom
wasn't with me and I was in the waiting
room and I was approached by a man and a
woman and I thought that they were
doctors or something I wasn't really
sure what was going on but then they
were telling you they were CSIS and I
was like what's
I didn't even realize that that's like
the Canadian CIA and then they told me
that the man I was married to was an al
Qaeda agent and he's connected to Osama
bin Laden and they've been following him
and he came to Canada I didn't know any
of this
he came to Canada with a fake Saudi
Arabian passport from Afghanistan and so
that's got red flags all over it yeah
and then they said don't tell your mom
don't tell him like we're going to try
and keep in contact with you and I was
like how I was this going to work
yeah but I was I I already had a
daughter by then I had a little baby and
I wanted I so wanted to get her out of
that world because I didn't want her to
have the same life that I'd had and when
they told me this it was like okay I
really need to to get out of this go and
all rights wait let's live boys forgive
me a lot of questions when you met him
so you obviously had no idea about any
of the history of the back writing did
at any point you suspect that something
was odd or fishy or did it all sort of
fit within sort of this conservative
religious whatever yeah so he was extra
conservative even even more so than my
family were really conservative but like
he made me wear the niqab like I
couldn't even show my eyes like I'd be
full covering of everything yeah I think
conservative isn't the right word it's
definitely not the right where are you
just hearing you say it that way yeah it
was like confusing them mm-hmm I don't
know what the right word is I mean
people these days use Islamist but it's
not even Islamist just describes a
person who wants to pull it like who
wants assignment politics because eager
to get it in like Sharia law implemented
or something like that but there are a
lot of problematic Muslims that don't
necessarily have political aspirations
but like so like somebody who honored
kills their child for example or who
wants like he wanted to perform FGM on
our daughter he
like when are we going to get her fixed
and I was like what would he mean fixed
and he's like you know cleaned up when
are we going to when are we going to
purify her and I was like I don't know
what you're talking about and I my mom
said oh no that's when she's older yes
but you can't do that when she's a baby
and then I realized what they were
talking about and so even though my mom
is from Egypt where this is like
prevalent she came from a really secular
kind of family and no kind of high class
like her her her her uncle was the first
president of Egypt so they were just
like oh yeah so like I was good she
Muhammad Muhammad Najib or in the GEEP
that's how I say I should go though yeah
well if he's only there for like a short
time but you know what I mean like so
she came from that kind of upbringing
where she had like nannies and cooks
chefs know it all cooks each other right
but that also is partly why maybe the
word conservative doesn't work they were
probably conservative in their own way
what they were in well she Islamists or
at least trying to instill
crazier parts of religion mm-hmm yeah
absolutely so she grew up in a super
secular home I sir I'm jumping around it
was someone's good yeah she grew up in a
super like almost European kind of
upbringing in Egypt like she went to
Catholic schools just because her
parents wanted her to learn French and
you know the nuns were that's where
that's the best French school and she
had Christian friends and it was like a
totally different world than what she
raised us in so she had that life and
her and my dad met and they you know
they lived in San Francisco and all like
that you know
hippie love peace in the 60s throws and
then they they moved to Canada and their
relationship fell apart so by then they
had three kids and my mom was all alone
with three children and so she kind of
you know she was like under 30 with
three children all by herself in a
brand-new country and so she was
approached
by some guy at the mosque because of
course that's what you do when you're
all by yourself and you have no
community so she went to the mosque
trying to find a community there and
this guy who was already married I
already had three kids of his own
offered to marry her as his like
concurrent second wife but the in-house
illegal income is not that I still do it
lots of them do it yeah because I guess
you know legally he's only married to
one right and then the other one is just
like so there's some sort of religious
contract but by yes I all by their
day-to-day life in affected to life yeah
yeah and so he the stipulation was she'd
have to start covering her hair and
she'd have to teach her kids how to pray
and read Quran and he came to our house
and he took all her records and he was
breaking them all because music is
forbidden and it was just like I
remember I was about five or six years
old at the time so it was a real shock
you know like Here I am like I'm allowed
to go swimming and and bike riding and
play with my non-muslim friends and have
like a normal life and then all of a
sudden he came in and it was just like
everything changed so I pushed back from
the very beginning because like now
birthdays aren't allowed like I can't
eat Oreo cookies anymore I can't have
hot dog day at school like all these
little with Oreos there's a large as
well there was larger than nothing yeah
yeah well no problem hello Mel yeah yeah
I'm not sure if that's progress or not
but all right here we are
Laurie I was excited when everything
stopped having larger I guess I eat all
this dude yeah even at five years old
this is changing in front of you and you
you instinctively knew something's not
right well you're taking away all the
stuff that kids love right like our
birthdays was huge because I was so
excited about finally getting a birthday
because I before that I was too young to
really remember but this that year I was
like who I'm going to plan a fun
birthday and and that it was like no
birthdays are hot on like everything
everything is hot on no more
swimming of our bike riding no more
playing with your friends even their
girls but they're not Muslim so you
can't be friends with them because
that's against Islam I mean I have to
explain that my my mom it was a student
at a lot hotter University and she was
the head of the Islamic Studies
department in the Islamic school that I
attended so she she knows her stuff
religiously she would and she followed
it verbatim so whenever she told us what
we were not allowed to do she would
always give us a hadith or the Quran
like the ayah the the verse to back up
why is she saying this yeah let's pause
there for one sec so for people that
have no idea without getting too much
into the religious part because I always
feel like for those of us that aren't
religious and we have this conversation
we get lost in talking about things they
don't even believe in which is sort of
annoying but can you just explain the
difference between the hadith and the
Quran so basically the Quran will will
will tell you what to do and then the
hadith will tell you how to do it and so
they had either based on how the Prophet
Mohammed lived so how did how did he do
things and as Muslims you're supposed to
try and follow as closely as possible
how he lives because he's a perfect
example of a perfect man and so we
follow or they follow whatever however
he lived his life that tell Muslims
should try and let theirs as well yeah
you're I'm oceans told most of the story
yeah yeah I guess it's things like you
know he married a six year old girl like
these are things that are happening
millions of girls across the planet
today are this is still happening
because people want to live in the same
way that he lived we have to follow his
example Isis are following his example
those horrible things happen when you
follow the example of this man right
yeah all right so we can get to some of
that stuff the political end of it later
but but a little more on your story here
when you're five you see this happening
how did you die girl going through that
I can't imagine ya is very unhappy and
how insular was it like once it started
so you basically were cut off right you
couldn't you couldn't where you going to
go five years old where you yeah yeah
and and it was just for me it was a
constant internal struggle because I
missed my old life and I and I wanted to
be like inside I wasn't able to be who I
was on the outside like on the outside I
had a hijab on and people look at me and
they're like Muslim meanwhile on the
inside I was like thinking like that's
not yeah but I thought the hijab was a
symbol of empowerment Braman yeah that's
what Linda Sarsour said her name yeah go
get these cockroaches are so mean
cholera in Arabic people thank okay so
let's talk about the the job produces
yeah it has to come yeah this this very
conflated symbol these days it's it's
almost the exact example of what
intersectionality is and how ridiculous
it is because the feminists are using
the hijab as a symbol of freedom or
something I was two weeks ago I was at a
street fair in West Hollywood which is
literally the gayest place on earth they
have rainbow crosswalks and there was
for gay guys they have a little
mannequin company then they're very gay
over the top and wonderful okay great
and they had a mannequin of a woman in a
fall in the club in the American flag
you know you could there's that picture
I think there's a picture they went
around and I saw it man
you guys are so missing the ball of
what's happening here so it's just a lot
better job for a second so that's
someone that wore it yeah when you see
it now being fetishized by Ramallah
what's happening here so it's really
just ignorant because they are
fetishizing it thinking that they are
celebrating people but really what
they're doing is they're celebrating
Islam they're celebrating a religion
which is crazy that it's coming from
liberal people who are atheists and and
they're celebrating religion like to me
it's the same as celebrating Mormon
underwear right or something you know or
like or Amish bonnet or apron or
whatever like you're celebrating a
far-right conservative Islamic thing
like most American women don't even wear
hijab but they're they're not even just
celebrating the religion but they're
celebrating the far-right aspect of the
religion and it's you is that the soft
bigotry of low expectations that somehow
that that's the only way they can view
you the only way they can somehow
empower you is to view you as a subject
yeah a little pets oh yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly it so they want to they
want to you know honor minorities or
celebrate differences or whatever fine
do that celebrate humans don't celebrate
their religion I mean they think of
Muslims as like you know if you if I
said for example you know I know a
Catholic person from the Philippines and
I know a Catholic person from Italy and
I know a Catholic person from Mexico you
would never think that all three of
these people share a culture well like
they share a religion really I'll share
a culture if I want to celebrate these
people then I'll celebrate Mexican
heritage and Italian heritage and
Filipino heritage and culture I'm not
going to celebrate Catholicism so that's
exactly what they're doing when they're
when they're celebrating a hijab you
know when when Hillary Clinton was
tweeting about the the woman that was in
the Olympics just because she had a
hijab on like yeah you're you're and
then I said again you've got the symbol
of the of the women's March which is so
incredibly confusing yeah it's a liberal
March and then your symbol is a far
right conservative Muslim like I think
they don't understand that just like
there's a spectrum in the United States
between left and right that same
spectrum exists you know in in in the
Muslim world as well yeah you've got
your left
you know liberal Majid Noah's for
example on on one side of the spectrum
and then you've got on the other side a
spectrum somebody who supports Sharia
law
Linda Cochran right a Linda Sarsour and
they're celebrating her right meanwhile
majid goes on the list of SPLC for being
an anti Muslim bigots yeah so liberals
are not supporting well we we've talked
about our children but quite literally
is on the Southern Poverty Law Center's
list of anti-muslim bigots are whatever
and ayaan Hirsi Ali is I mean this is
the height of hypocrisy
yeah and ridiculous yeah so instead of
liberal supporting other liberals
liberals are supporting conservative and
and just because she happens to have
brown skin so therefore we need to just
celebrate everything that she does she
supports Sharia law but it's but that's
okay because you know right I mean I'm
sure you saw it I think we went back and
forth a little bit on Twitter when this
happened but she has all these old
tweets defending Sharia law and then
there's just it might be the most vile
thing I've ever read on Twitter where
she talks about basically in effect says
that ayaan Hirsi Ali and Brigitte
Gabriel have coming on showing the
public that they don't deserve to have
their vaginas knowing full well that I
on underwent FGM and this woman is is
the leader of the women's March Bernie
is literally tweeting hashtag I stand
with Linda so what what do we do about
this because this has been the theme
when I've talked to you and I've talked
to Sarah and Ali and Faisal and all of
these people who I only judge you
individually by what you're telling me
right now how do we unfurl some of this
nonsense well I think it it all comes
down to identity politics and identity
politics is basically just a nice way of
saying you know racism or bigotry really
it's just a nuance to bigotry so people
on the Left can see that that you know
alt writer
are just all about you know skin color
and they're like oh we're not going to
do that we're going to do the opposite
we're going to also be all about skin
color right it's so opposite it to say
it's so oh this is the same I mean I
think both ends of the spectrum I don't
know which one is crazier than the other
to be honest like the far right people
think that I'm a closeted Islamist and
the far left people think that I'm a
closeted bigot you know all writer
actually so they're both delusional
obviously and you know what they don't
matter because I think that those two
groups are really small minorities and I
think that most of us are sane rational
people in the middle and I think that if
you could just explain to people like if
they just spent a little bit of time
understanding that this is a religious
symbol and you're supporting a religion
right now and a religion by the way
which would subjugate you remember stat
yeah I'm looking far you're a you're an
apostate even though this is not great
for us no no I mean anybody non-muslim
would be killed yeah so you know but
like look what's happening which has
happened in Egypt you do know is 90%
Muslim 10% you know of non-muslim still
isn't good enough right we're still
going to kill them while they're while
they're in prayer so it's not like
anybody is going to be left off the hook
you know doesn't it's not just if you're
an apostate er if you're gay or it's
anybody that is non-muslim yeah you're
all up for grabs yeah I mean it's a
whole other discussion but Egypt is such
a sad example Tube I was at in Egypt 20
years ago 1997 I had a great time there
for a week and I when I was in Israel
before and I went there with Israeli
passport stamps on life has work went
Egypt went through Sinai was therefore
we could put you'd have to be crazy to
do that these days because of the way
extremism is yeah yeah and if there's a
video online I've come out the Nauset
who it was about in the 1950s where he
was talking about the Muslim Brotherhood
came to him and they were telling him we
want you to put a hijab all the women
and he was laughing at them and people
in the audience were laughing and
they're like tell him to wear it and all
I've seen the video it's like a kind of
a whole group of people in Parliament
yeah
and with that happened in the in the 50s
and people thought it was a joke so
people really of course we're not going
to become conservative here you know but
a look at look at Egypt today right and
that that's sort of what I see happening
in the rest of the world so in Europe
they kind of have that same attitude of
like oh that's not going to happen to us
meanwhile there's over 80 courts for
Sharia law there's areas of France that
are gender segregated you know like this
this idea of like oh that's never going
to happen to us is something that a lot
of people have said before and they've
all been proven wrong so I think that we
need to be more vigilant more aware more
in the same way that we're very careful
to keep Christianity out we should be
just as careful with keeping Islam out
right and that's why I talk about this
so much because it's like everyone will
go nuts on the Left they'll go nuts over
the one Baker who won't bake the cake
and yet at the same time they'll then
fetishized with a job or anything else
[Music]
you